Welcome to my online class on statistics.
The basics of statitics is that the world is full of data,
and we the people have to make decisions.
Statistics comes to our rescue.
It takes data and turns it into information that we the people can use to make decisions.
Whether you are in social sciences, medicine, engineering, public policy,
psychology, climatology, robotics, even archaeology, health sciences,
finance, business and marketing, or pretty much any other discipline that you can study.
All of those are now driven by data, including unlikely fields like biology or physics
and so many others.
Statistics is an amazing discipline to know.
It is universal, useful, and fun, as I hope you're going to see in the class I'm just about to teach.